Guten Abend.
Guten Abend Herr Doktor.
Ich heiße Mohamed Hamidi.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistentarzt tätig und möchte und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie einverstanden?
Wie heißen Sie Doktor Mohamed?
Mohamed Hamidi, ja.
Kommen Sie aus Saudi-Arabien?
Aus Syrien.
Aus Syrien?
Ah, ja, das ist ein schlimmer Krieg dort gewesen.
Ja, genau. Deswegen bin ich her.
Okay, freut mich sehr. Ich hoffe, es geht Ihnen gut Herr Doktor.
Dankeschön.
Zuerst stelle ich ein paar allgemeine Fragen und dann kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Ist es in Ordnung?
Ja, natürlich gerne Doktor.
Ich bin extra hier in diese Notaufnahme gekommen, weil hier gute Ärzte sind Herr Doktor.
Ja, ich hoffe auch.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Franz Decker.
Franz Decker.
Ja bitte.
Konnten Sie bitte Nachname buchstabieren?
Mein Nachname ist Decker.
Ich buchstabiere Dora Emil C. Saar.
K. Wie Karl? Emil Richard.
Konnten Sie nur buchstaben sagen ohne?
Also Decker. D. E. C.
C.
K. E. R.
Decker.
Decker, genau.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Ja, und wann Sie sind genau geboren?
Sie möchten mein Geburtstatus.
Ich muss mal bauen, das ist der 23. April 1968.
Okay, und wie groß sind Sie?
1,73 Meter.
Sie wollen wahrscheinlich jetzt auch mein Gewicht wissen.
115 kg.
Ja, Sie haben Obergewicht.
Ja, leider so ein bisschen.
Ich will Sie wissen, dass.
Okay, Herr Decker.
Konnten Sie, was führt Sie zu uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Also Herr Dr. Mohamed.
Ich habe seit 2 Tagen zu einem komischen Druck auf der Brust.
Und seit gestern tut mir auch der Rücken weh.
Und das macht mir jetzt ein bisschen Angst.
Okay, Herr Decker.
Konnten Sie mir sagen, wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Also wenn ich hier drauf zeige, hier auf der linken Brust helfte,
das geht so ein bisschen über der gesamte Brust.
Okay, und strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin?
Zum Beispiel linker Schulter oder Arm?
Schulter jetzt nicht, aber ich kann es schlecht sagen,
ob jetzt die Schmerzen vom Rücken nach vorne kommen
oder von vorne nach hinten.
Also ich habe auch Rückenschmerzen auf dieser Höhe.
Zwischen den Schulterblättern.
Ich verstehe aus Strahlung nach Rücken.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob Sie von Rücken nach vorne kommen
oder ob die Brutzen von vorne nach hinten gehen.
Beides ist da.
Okay.
Und sind die Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich aufgenommen?
Langsam, aber die sind sehr stark jetzt geworden seit zwei Tagen.
Und immer stärker.
Auf wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leichter
und sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht.
Also langsam, wir haben langsam begonnen,
das war vielleicht bei 2, 3 und sind jetzt ungefähr bei 7, 8 gelandet.
2, 3 am Anfang und jetzt 7, 8.
Ja, würde ich schon sagen.
Es ist so, dass ich schlecht Luft bekomme.
Wenn ich einatme, dann habe ich das Gefühl, es sticht manchmal
und ich kann nicht tief durchatmen.
Sie können keinen tief atmen.
Ja, das fehlt mir.
Weil bei tief atmen, die Schmerzen sich verstärken.
Ja.
Und da haben Sie eng geholen?
Ja, also seit heute habe ich auch das Gefühl,
als ob mir so ein Elefant auf der Brust sitzt.
Und haben Sie Atemnot?
Also ich tue, wie gesagt, ich tue mich schwer zu atmen.
Ja, das wird immer schlimmer.
Ja, ich habe verstanden, Sie haben Schmerzen bei tiefen Atmen,
aber nicht Atemnot.
Aber Sie haben Atemnot.
Wenn ich mich belaste, wenn ich versuche, auf Toilette zu gehen
und eine Wohnung zu laufen, dann fällt mir das schon schwer.
Das bedeutet bei leichter Belastung.
Ja, bei leichter Belastung.
Haben Sie schon einmal eine ähnliche Beschwerden für die Höhe?
Also ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe vor zehn Jahren schon mal
einen Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Da habe ich sehr viel geraucht und hatte hohen Blutdruck.
Die Schmerzen waren ähnlich, aber noch schlimmer.
Vor zehn Jahren, und Sie sind jetzt 44, das bedeutet, Sie waren jung.
Relativ jung.
Ich bin jetzt 54.
44, okay.
Und das war ungefähr vor zehn Jahren, da war ich 44.
Noch jung.
Das bedeutet, Sie rauchen sehr viel.
Also bis zum Herzinfarkt habe ich viel geraucht.
Und nach dem Herzinfarkt aber nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist gut.
Okay, Herr Decker, haben Sie schwindelisch oder ist Ihnen schwindelisch?
Nein, ich habe keine Schwindel.
Aber ich habe eine leichte Übelkeit.
Und erbrochen?
Nein.
Obelkeit auch seit zwei Tagen?
Das seit heute.
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden, wirklich diese Brust oder Bauch?
Ich habe Ihre Frage nicht ganz verstanden, Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Nein, das ist genug, das reicht mir.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich meine, in Haars zum Beispiel, Schluckte,
ist es mehr auf die Brust und dann rücken.
Okay, haben Sie die Brust?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen, war mir das nicht.
Okay, schütteln Brust auch rein, ja?
Nein, nein, nein.
Haben Sie Störungen, Wasser lassen und Stuhlgang?
Nein, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Herr Decker, leider sehen Sie an chronischen Krankungen,
zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck.
Ich habe jetzt nicht Bluthochdruck, ich nehme auch Medikamente,
wie gesagt, seit dem Herzinfarkt.
Ja.
Ansonsten, Sie sehen, ich habe ein bisschen Übergewicht
und mein Kohle Sterin ist halt hoch.
Seit wann haben Bluthochdruck?
Also, das ist damals mit dem Herzinfarkt aufgefallen.
Aufgefahren, ja.
Wo hatte ich keine Medikamente, war mir das nicht bekannt?
Ja, bevor die Herzinfarkte, es war nicht diagnostiziert.
Nein, nein, ich war auch kaum beim Arzt,
ich habe mich ja eigentlich gesund gefühlt.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Und Kohle Sterin, werte seit wann auch, sind?
Ja, alles seit dem Herzinfarkt.
Da war ich, davor war ich ja nie beim Arzt, deswegen.
Ja, das ist wie Backit.
Ja, genau, hat man nicht festgestellt, genau.
Ja, ganz wie Backit.
Leiden Sie oder haben Sie alleerbischen gegen etwas?
Nein, bisher nicht, nein.
Und Unverträglichkeit?
Wie meinen Sie Unverträglichkeit?
Zum Beispiel Laktos und Toleranz oder Gluten und Toleranz.
Ich bin dauerlicherweise alles essen und trinken, Sie sehen in meinem Bauch.
Ja, gut.
Sehr gerne.
Herr Mohamed, überprüfen Sie bitte die Vitalpermite des Patianten
und fahren Sie dann mit Iran im Nesefort.
Ja, okay.
Der blühten Druck ist ein bisschen vor.
Es ist 180 zu 100.
Das ist hoch, ja.
Das ist ja manchmal, aber vielleicht ist das der Grund,
weil ich schon Druck auf den Brust habe.
Herr Decker, ich gebe Ihnen ein Tablet.
Ein Helm mit einer Reaktion, bitte zeigen.
Ich möchte ein e-k-Geschrei von der Vitalparamite überprüfen,
wie blühten Druck, die Leichtoff-KB, der ZDG,
die ZDG, die die ZDG haben.
Ich möchte das mit einer Reaktion, wie blühten Druck,
die Leichtoff-KB, die ZDG, die Leichtoff-KB,
der ZDG, die Leichtoff-KB, die Leichtoff-KB,
100 und die Pulse ist 100 pro Minute. So, ich sollte Ihnen Sauerstoff geben und eine Tablette
bliege unter die Zange. Unter den Zungen, okay. Ja, und wir warten einige Minuten und dann
wir weiter die Anamnese gesprich vor. Machen Sie auch ein EKG-Doctor oder kommt das mit?
Ja natürlich, ja natürlich, die Schwester kommt gerade und EKG machen. Ja, natürlich.
Gut, EKG. Vielen Dank, es geht mir ein bisschen besser. Das EKG ist auch ganz gut. Es ist ein
Synos-Rhythmus, keine Hebungen. Okay, wir zurückkommen zum Gespräch.
Sind Sie gegen Kinderkrankheit geimpft? Das hat mein Haushaltsüberprüft, ja.
Ja, okay. Und gegen Corona? Bin ich auch geimpft, ich habe Ihnen drei Impfungen. Das letzte war vor
fünf Monaten. Wie ist Ihnen Ihre Appetit? Es ist ein Appetit.
Er war sehr gut. Beide Tage nicht so gut, aber ansonsten leider zu gut.
Okay, und Herr Decker, Rauchen, Sie haben gesagt, vorher, Sie haben viele.
Ja, und könnte mir sagen, ein bisschen mehr über die Rauchen, wie viel Zigaretin
geraucht und wie lange gezeigt. Das war viel, ich habe ungefähr eine Schachtel am Tag geraucht.
Und das über, sicherlich über 20 Jahre. Umgefähr vor 20 Jahren.
Okay, und trinken Sie Alkohol? Ja. Wie viel und was Sie trinken?
Ja gut, ich trinke immer am Abend mal eine Flasche Bier, manchmal auch mehr und manchmal trinke ich auch so einen Rotfall.
Ein Glas? Ja, je nachdem, was es ist, auch mal ein bisschen mehr.
Und Herr Decker, nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich, es ist einfach eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen oder hatten Sie?
Meine größte Droge ist Schokolade.
Wir haben jeden Abend zwei Tafeln Schokolade verdruckt.
Aber andere Drogen habe ich glücklicherweise nicht.
Ja, nachdem wir darüber sprechen, ich merke auch viel Schokolade.
Okay, Herr, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Bauningenieur.
Meine Aufgabe ist es auf den Baustellen, die als Bauleiter die Arbeiten zu kontrollieren.
Und sind Sie für das Erwartet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ein Tochter und einen Sohn und die sind gesund glücklicherweise.
Und leben Sie alles zusammen?
Nein, die Kinder haben sie natürlich schon länger aus dem Haus.
Die haben beide studiert, die eine ist jetzt in Hamburg.
Sie ist Ärztin und der Sohn ist Betriebswirt, der ist nach München gegangen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und dann leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau?
Ja, ich wollte meine Frau.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder bei der Familie?
Im Alltag habe ich genug, natürlich.
Im Beruf ist natürlich viel zu tun und da ist auch viel Stress.
Viel Stress.
Herr Decker, ich stelle eine Frage über Familie einem Neese.
Lernen Ihre Eltern noch?
Mein Vater lebt noch, aber meine Mutter ist letztes Jahr verstorben leider.
Woran verstorben?
Sie hatte leider ein Krebs und ist dann am Folgen des Krebs verstorben.
Das ging leider nicht.
Wie sind Sie welche Krebs?
Ein gynecologischer Krebs, ich glaube.
Gynecologischer, aber sie ist nicht.
Und Ihr Vater leidet alleine?
Aber dem geht es gut.
Keine Erklanten.
Der nimmt zwar keine Tabletten, der ist auch gesund,
er versorgt sich alleine.
Der ist sportlich.
Ich hoffe auch, dass Sie nach diesem Problem behandeln.
Auch Sie Sport machen, ich empfehle.
Ich will immer gerne, aber ich habe leider nie die Zeit dazu.
Okay, darüber reden wir später.
Herr Doktor, was glauben Sie, was ich habe?
Ja, ich habe sie.
Ist es etwas Schlimmes?
Ist es mit einem Herzinfarkt?
Ja, ich habe sie.
Ich habe die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufugeln?
Ich möchte wissen, was es ist, Herr Doktor.
Sie haben mich so gefragt.
Auf dem EKG haben Sie keine Fragen zum Glück.
Aber leider haben Sie meine Verdachtdiagnose
Herzkrankheit, Corona-Herzkrankheit.
Das habe ich ja schon gesagt.
Vor zehn Jahren habe ich ein Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Ja, leider kommen Sie noch einmal.
Sie haben sie aber gewischt.
Sie haben welche Medikamente Sie nehmen?
Sie wollen meine Medikamente.
Ich habe mehrere Medikamente.
Ja, Sie können mir sagen.
Ich habe zum einen das Aspirin 100.
Dann habe ich Metaprolol 95.
Dann nehme ich eine Tabletin.
Metaprolol 95.
Dann nehme ich Ramipri 5.
Ich habe etwas gegen das Cholesterin.
Das ist Artorvastatin 40.
Ich sage, Sie haben noch einmal eine Corona-Herzkrankheit.
Was heißt eine neue Corona-Herzkrankheit?
Ist es ein Herzinfarkt oder etwas anderes?
Ja, das gerne sein, weil auf dem EKG
nicht schnell sein kann.
Wir machen noch einmal EKG später.
Aber wir brauchen Korbisch- und Laborentersuchungen.
Dann können wir entscheiden, ob Sie Herzinfarkt oder nur Karhäker haben.
Ich bitte Ihnen, ein paar Minuten gedürft zu sein.
Soll ich hier warten, während Sie mich wachen?
Sie bleiben hier.
Ihr Sauerstoff muss dauerhaft bekommen.
Dann gleich mit der Sister Korbisch- und Laborentersuchung durchführen.
Und wann nehmen Sie Blut ab?
Jetzt.
Direkt nach dem Korbisch- und Laborentersuchung.
Dann warten wir hier.
Ich bitte Ihnen, ein paar Minuten gedürft zu sein.
Ja, ein paar Minuten.
Nein.
Nicht, Schwindel hatte gefragt, aber kalt schweiß ich, bin ich nicht.
Aber Sie haben nicht gefragt, ob ich Unterschenkelödem habe,
ob ich eine Reise hinter mir habe,
als Differenzialdiagnose.
Wie viel kissen Benüsunzi zum Schlafen?
Genau, ein Kissen reicht mir.
Wie viel Reisen?
Keine Reisen.
Ich habe nicht.
Manchmal, wenn ich am Abend spät esse, habe ich etwas aufgestoßen.
Ich habe auch eine Reise hinter mir,
die ich in der Taubhaus-Gefür hatte.
Nein, nein.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, ob ich eine Reise hinter mir habe.
Ja, war der.
Wurden Sie einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich habe schon mehrere Operationen hinter mir.
Ja, bitte schön.
Also ich hatte vor fünf Jahren mein rechtes Knie operiert worden.
Da hatte ich so ein Miniskusriss.
Vor 15 Jahren ist mein Blinddarm operiert.
Blinddarm operiert als 15 Jahre alt?
Vor 15 Jahren.
Da hatte ich eine Blinddarmperforation.
Dann hatte ich eine Züste am Nebenholding.
Das ist vor sechs Jahren operiert worden.
Vor 20 Jahren hatte ich eine Steißbein-Fistel.
Das war eine ganz schlimme OP.
Da musste ich sechs Wochen mit einer offenen Wunderung laufen.
Das war sehr unangenehm.
Entschuldigung.
Noch einmal konnten Sie wiederholen, die vor der Krankung gehen.
Vor 10 Jahren.
Vor Operationen, meinen Sie.
Also wie gesagt, ein Miniskusriss.
Dann Blinddarm-OP.
Blind...
Vor 10 Jahren.
15 Jahre.
Blinddarm-OP.
Und vor 10 Jahren...
Da hatte ich eine Züste am Nebenholding.
Züste am Nebenholding.
Ich glaube, das nennt sich Spermatozene oder so ähnlich.
Ja.
Und...
Was habe ich gesagt vorhin?
Genau.
Eine Steißbein-Fistel.
Steißbein.
Fistel.
Sie haben gesagt, vor 10 Jahren ein Ersinfakt gehabt.
Ja.
Und welche...
wurden Sie...
ist es wirklich behandelt, oder?
Ja, gut, nach dem Ersinfakt hat mein Herzkathetiker natürlich auf einen Stand bekommen.
Ein Stand bekommen.
Ja, ja.
Regelmäßig beim Kardiologen.
Der sagt, bisher ist alles in Ordnung.
Ja, und Sie haben gesagt, Perfuration aber nicht...
gut gehören.
Perfurationen.
Blinddarm.
Ja.
Starknzen.
Machen wir den Arztübergabe.
Ja.
Gibt es noch eine Frage?
Nein.
Wir machen jetzt den Arztübergabe, Oberarzt.
Ja, okay.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Hallo, liebe Kollege.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen die neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich.
Aber natürlich bitteschön.
Was haben Sie denn?
Sein Name ist Franz Decker.
Er ist 54 Jahre alt und zwar geboren am 23. April 1968.
Er ist 1,73 m groß und wiegt 115 kg.
Ganz schön viel, ja?
Ja, sehr.
Herr Decker stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit 2 Tagen bestehenden
Rhetorsternellen, Schmerzen mit Ausstrahlung,
mit Rückenausstrahlung in den Rücken.
Er berichtete, dass die Schmerzen am Anfang 2, 3 auf der Skala von 10,
und im Laufe der Zeit die Schmerzen 7, 8 von 10 angestiegen sind.
Er berichtete auch über tiefe Atmenschmerzen
und Enggelfung.
Wo sind die Schmerzen bei tiefer Inspiration?
An den Mittellbrust und Ausstrahlung nach dem Rücken.
Sind Sie stechend, dumpf, oder was meint ihr mit Schmerzen?
Was für hart von Schmerzen sind das?
Das ist nicht gesteht.
Er hat stechende Schmerzen bei tiefer Inspiration.
Er berichtete, dass Atem das Rüstbneue bei leichter Belästung auftreten wurde.
Er berichtete, dass er vor 10 Jahren Herzinfarkt hatte.
Und danach eine Stentoppe durchgeführt.
Er hat eine Corona-Angeografie mit Stent-Implantation.
Die Frage nach Obelkeit, Erbröschen,
die er lassen und Sturrungen verneint wurden.
Die Abität zurzeit ist ein bisschen verwendet.
Aber sonst ist der Abität sehr gut.
Er klagte, dass die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten sind.
Und sich im Laufe der Zeit verschwemmet werden.
An Vorerkrankungen sind bekannt.
Er hat seit 10 Jahren Atelierhypertonie.
Er leidet an Obergewicht.
Er hat eine Frage nach Allergien und Unverzweglichkeit verneint.
Der Patient nimmt 100 mg morgens oder einmal pro Tag mit 190 mg.
195 mg.
99 mg.
45 mg.
95 mg.
Und 20 mg abends.
Herr Dekker hat vorher geraucht.
Ein Packung pro Tag vor 20 Jahren.
Aber nach dem Herzinfarkt nicht mehr.
Alkohol.
Er bringt ein oder manchmal mehr Flasche Bier pro Tag.
Manchmal erbringt Rotwein, ein Glas oder mehr.
Die Familie ergeben einen krebsgenetischen, genekologischen Krebs bei Mutter.
Er weiß nicht, welcher genau ist.
Der Vater ist gestorben.
Mutter oder Vater?
Mutter, genekologische Krebs.
Und ist an dem Krebs verstorben.
Mutter ist verstorben.
Vater ist gesund.
Mutter ist an genekologischen Krebs verstorben.
Herr Dekker ist Bauingenieur.
Er ist verheiratet und hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Er liebt mit der Frau zusammen.
Er hat viel Stress bei Arbeit.
Die Impfstätigkeit ist vollständig.
Er ist dreimal gegen Covid-19 geimpft.
Das war der Ernest.
Er ist auf einem nächsten Angriff.
Er ist von Herzinfarkt aus.
Wie ist das Labor?
Wir haben einen Labor gemacht.
Wenn Sie sagen, es ist ein Herzinfarkt, dann brauchen Sie ein Labor.
Die ZK und ZK-MB sind erhöhte.
Er ist von Herzinfarkt aus erhöht.
Welcher Wert ist erhöht?
Was war am EKG?
Er hat beim ersten EKG keine ST-Hebungen gehabt.
Er hat nach ihrem EKG eine ST-Streckenhebung.
Er hat einen Akuten-Myokartinfarkt.
Das Labor hat einen positiven Troponientest.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Wir bleiben bei uns.
Wir haben schon ein paar Medikamente gemacht.
Was braucht der Patient?
Wir haben einen Antigoagulant-Medikament.
Das ist wichtig.
Das ist das Arspyriene.
Wir sind in der Klinik.
Das ist für Langit.
Wir haben eine Tropocinase.
Wir haben eine Erdkarte.
Wir wollen eine Lusiterapie machen.
Eine operative Trompenempfernung.
Wir sind akut und frisch.
Wir können die Schaden bekommen.
Wir machen die Trombus.
Wenn die Medikamente nicht los ist,
dann machen wir eine operative Trompenempfernung.
Wir machen eine Corona-Angiografie.
Was sind Ihre Diagnose?
Was kann man noch denken?
Keine Herzinfarkt.
Was ist eine Stabilung?
Das ist Stabilung.
Wenn er immer wieder Schmerzen hat,
dann ist es eine Stabilung.
Was ist eine Stabilung?
Wir haben wegen der Lungenembuli nicht gefragt,
ob er eine Reise hatte, ob er eine Trombose hatte,
ob er eine Trombose hatte,